artificial intelligence has emerged as a
transformative technology that is
revolutionizing various aspects of our
lives with its ability to simulate human
intelligence and perform complex tasks
as for an application in fields ranging
from Healthcare to finance e-commerce to
manufacturing transportation and
entertainment to much more so let me
tell you or share some fascinating
statistics with you that illustrate the
impact and potential of this game
changing technology before we related
the fascinating world of artificial
intelligence now according to a study by
Grant view research the global AI Market
was valued at around 39.9 billion
dollars in 2019 and is projected to
reach 733.7 billion dollars by 2027.
isn't that great which is growing at a
cager of 42.7 percent from 2020 to 2027.
the scope of a encompasses a wide range
of areas where intelligent machines can
augment or replace human capabilities
such as machine learning which is a
subset of AI which enables systems to
learn and improve from data without
explicit programming this has led to
advancement in natural language
processing computer vision pattern
recognization enabling AI powered
chatbots image recognition systems
recommendation systems through deep
learning and natural language processing
now AAS transforming industries by
automating repetitive tasks improving
efficiency and enabling data driven
decision making now in healthcare AI
algorithms can analyze medical images
assist in diagnosis and predict diseases
outcomes in finance AI Power Systems
automatic trading detect fraud and
provide personalized Financial advice in
transportation wealth Transportation
also benefits from AI through autonomous
vehicles route optimization and traffic
prediction so not only these sectors you
can find the various uses of AI in
various other sectors as well which is
growing at a rapid rate so let us
discuss some of the future trends of AI
now future of AI holds tremendous
promise and potential as technology
continues to advance AI is expected to
become more dedicated and capable now
some key trends that will shape the
future of AI include deep learning
advancements in neural networks and deep
learning algorithms will lead to more
accurate and complex AI models capable
of handling diverse tasks ethical AI
there is growing emphasis on developing
AI systems that are fair transparent and
unbiased efforts are being made to
address ethical concerns such as privacy
accountability and algorithm biases as
AI becomes more pervasive there is
growing emphasis on ethics and
regulations so efforts will be made to
ensure responsible and unbiased AI
development AI in robotics the
integration of AI with robotics will
lead to the development of intelligent
robots capable of Performing complex
tasks in diverse Industries such as
manufacturing Logistics Healthcare and
much more Ai and iot now the combination
of AI and iot will enable Smart Homes
cities and industries where
interconnected devices leverage AI
algorithms to collect and analyze data
for better decision making and
automation AI in personalization AI will
continue to enhance personalized
experience in various domains such as
entertainment e-commerce marketing by
understanding user preferences and
delivering tailored recommendations to
them autonomous systems now the
development of autonomous systems
including self-driving cars drones and
Robotics will continue to advance as
well so these systems rely on AI
algorithms and sensors to perceive and
interact with the environment leading to
advancement in transportation Logistics
and other Industries as well AI for
social good now not only for technology
AI has the potential to address societal
changes in areas like climate change
Healthcare accessibility and poverty
elevation as well it can help optimize
resource allocation enable productive
modeling and support decision making in
tackling all these Global issues and
finally human AI collaboration now
rather than replacing humans AI is
expected to augment human capabilities
and enable more effective collaboration
AI systems can assist in decision making
automate reputation task and provide
personal recommendation to users and
allowing humans to focus on High level
tasks that reward creativity and
critical thinking so learning a offers
numerous benefits ranging from career
opportunities and Innovation to personal
growth and ethical consideration it
equips you with valuable skills and
knowledge that can have a profound
impact on various aspects of society and
the World At Large but choosing the
right course to excel in the field of AI
can be challenging at times with so many
options available out there in the
market how do you know which one is
right for you well we are here to help
you so without any further Ado let's
discuss the top 5 best certifications in
AI so first on the list we have Masters
in artificial intelligence program now
this Masters program in artificial
intelligence is one of the most sought
after courses offered by simplylearn
this artificial intelligence Masters
program in collaboration with IBM
introduces students to Blended learning
and prepares them to be specialist in AI
now this program you will teach you the
necessary skills you need to become an
AI expert and land in your dream job
this course covers the basic
fundamentals of Python programming
languages and its proper libraries like
numpy and pandas from the scratch to
some Advanced topics like machine
learning algorithms deep learning NLP
computer vision AI deployment by
covering some important tools like Keras
tensorflow sci-fi and much more so what
else can you expect from this program
well this course also includes three
Capstone and dual industry relevant
projects from the likes of Amazon
Walmart Mercedes-Benz Uber and many more
immersive learning experience eight
times higher live interaction in live AI
online classes delivered by season
trainers and Industry experts so what
are you waiting for don't miss out this
chance to take your carry to Next Level
enroll in our artificial intelligence
Masters program today I'll start your
journey to become an AI expert the coast
link is added in the description box
below and pin comment second on the list
we have the AI and machine learning
bootcamp this air machine learning
bootcamp program May develop your career
as an expert in artificial intelligence
in collaboration with Celtic University
this AIML bootcamp offers master classes
by Caltech professors live classes
taught by industry experts Interactive
lab sessions and project relevant to the
industry now this bootcamp offers
caltech's academic Excellence simply
learns career assistance campus
inversion and hands-on experience this
Ai and ml bootcamp will help you get
noticed by top hiring companies and
helps you in the industry relevant
Capstone projects so this air machine
learning bootcamp by Caltech is the best
option for anyone wishing to get a
Competitive Edge in the air of
cutting-edge Technologies this bootcamp
offers a complete understanding of
ai-based Technologies like machine
learning neural language processing deep
learning speech recognition and much
more so choosing this boot camp can get
you hired by Renault companies like
Microsoft Google IBM Amazon Samsung and
much more so this bootcamp has benefited
many aspiring Ai and ml engineers and
professionals so what are you waiting
for enrolled today in this a and ml
bootcamp link is in the description box
below and pin comment now third on the
list we have MSN artificial intelligence
now gain the right skills to achieve top
level career position with this MSN
Artificial Intelligence online program
this 20 performance Ms and artificial
intelligence leverages IU's mix of
in-person and online classes and simply
learn supplementary skills to help you
build a network socialize and benefit
from Real Life practical teaching this
rigorous training program helps students
learn about powerful technology from
scratch and develop work-ready AI skills
it covers Concepts like machine learning
natural language processing computer
vision and focuses of study on AI
applications as a student in the MS in
artificial intelligence you will learn
how to develop intelligent systems
analyze and interpret data and design
algorithms to make decisions and
accurate predictions now some of the key
features of this program include dual
degree with London South Bank University
or lcsbu end-to-end VISA and admission
support through simple and study abroad
assist 18 months post study work visa
and much more you will learn
fundamentals of AI and machine learning
Concepts and get hands-on experience
with Technologies like R python machine
learning Tableau Hadoop spark now as we
progress we'll explore the fascinating
realm of deep learning discussing neural
networks their architecture and their
ability to learn complex pattern by
enrolling in this Ms and artificial
intelligence program you can surely
embark on a carrier as a data scientist
AI researcher machine learning engineer
AI engineer and much more so what are
you waiting for so are you ready to
unlock the power of AI and take your
carry to new heights if so enroll in RMS
in artificial intelligence program today
and become part of an AI Revolution
course link is added the description box
below and pin comment make sure you
check that out now fourth on the list we
have ai quotation making business
strategies and applications now this AF
audition making program imparts in-depth
knowledge of Big Data Ai and machine
learning and how to apply them across
the three key business functions like
marketing finance and people management
as well so this program covers the risks
and ethics of using Ai and how you can
design governance Frameworks for
Effective AI implementation now this AI
program in collaboration with Wharton
online is designed to offer
professionals from diverse backgrounds
comprehensive training in the most
in-demand skills and Technologies needed
to succeed as an AI business developer
by helping you build a strong foundation
in Technologies like big data a and
machine learning you will learn how to
apply them in key business functions
like Finance marketing and much more by
end of the artificial intelligence
program you will have a clear
understanding of preventive analytics
reinforcement learning logistic
regression deep learning recommendation
systems and how to apply AI for solving
real world business problems some of the
key features of this program are
exclusive AI program course content
co-created by eight of the top Wharton
professors monthly live online classes
delivered by distinguished water faculty
and upon successful completion of this
course you will get a globally
recognized what an online certification
interesting right so what are you
waiting for enroll now in af audition
making program and stay ahead of the
curve course link is added in the
description box you can check that out
and finally on the list we have Caltech
postgraduate program in Ai and ml now
this Caltech portrait program in air
machine learning offered by simply learn
is an online program designed to provide
students with a comprehensive
understanding of AI and machine learning
Concepts tools and its techniques this
program is created in collaboration with
Caltech ctme and IBM and is designed to
provide Learners with a strong
foundation in Ain machine learning this
course covers various topics such as
statistics deep learning computer vision
NLP which will help you gain the right
skill set on various tools such as
carats matplotlab tensorflow Django and
much more now furthermore the curriculum
is structured around interactive online
classes live sessions with industry
experts and Hands-On projects as well so
overall the Caltech postgraduate program
in a and machine learning offered by
simpler is a well-structured and
comprehensive program that can help you
gain expertise in Ai and enhance your
career in this Prospect again upon
completion of this course students will
receive a postgraduate certificate from
Caltech ctme and IBM indicating that
they have acquired the necessary skills
and knowledge to apply AI learning
Concepts in real world situations so
hurry up enroll now in the Caltech post
budget program in Ai and ML and create
your own successful career so with this
we have come to the end of the top AI
certifications I hope the video was
informative and interesting if you have
any further queries regarding any of the
courses covered in this video or need
any help or out for any of these boot
camps please feel free to let us know in
the comment section below and a team of
experts should be more than happy to
help us all your queries at the earliest
also don't forget to subscribe to Simply
learn from more such amazing content
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here